people love the internet retro Records
who are here and we just got a brand new
sneak peek at the art and making of
Hogwarts Legacy the game's official art
book including some new details and even
some preview images we're gonna dive in
right now this all comes courtesy from
an article on sci-fi.com we'll link it
down in the description below okay so it
starts off with kind of a little bit of
an intro here to Hogwarts so I can see a
lot of stuff you guys are already going
to know and be familiar with but here is
when they get into the new stuff talking
about the art book the first of its kind
title will be accompanied by a 252-page
art book chronicling The Magical amount
of detail needed to bring such an
Endeavor to life on sale from inside
editions next month you can pre-order
copyright here for 45 the art of making
of Hogwarts Legacy exploring the
unwritten Wizarding World was written by
Jody revinson and Michael Owen both of
whom got a front row seat to the game's
ever evolving development process and
then here through all the days of
working on this more and more incredible
artwork would arrive for us to see and
guys as you know we've seen some of this
already in the behind the scenes and the
dev interviews that they've done in it
looks phenomenal and 252 pages I mean
really are you kidding me I can't wait
for this characters would be refined and
settings would be developed it was a
very exciting experience revitson who is
no stranger to peeling back the curtain
on The Wizarding World tells sci-fi wire
oh and by the way we've got an exclusive
sneak peek inside the wondrous
publication which is rich in original
illustrations the cover art included and
so here is the very first image that we
see it looks like this is going to be
the first thing you see I mean when you
open the book I could see this being on
that inside left flap right here looks
like a shot of hogsmead here with three
broomsticks and then we also have a
honeydukes over here and then just over
here the art of making Hogwarts Legacy
written by Jody Riverson and Michael
Owen next page here now we are into the
table of contents and there are some
interesting details but don't worry no
spoilers here got the Sorting Hat over
here on the left and then chapter one
the first mission on page eight ancient
Magic on page 20 a Wizards Field Guide
22 chapter 2 where our story starts the
players choices on page 80. I find this
one super interesting because they've
sort of played up our choices at times
and then at other times they said well
there's no real moral system or anything
like that but to see that reconfirmed
here that hey your choices are going to
be important clearly they're showing
them in the art book here I think that's
a really good sign then you have
cinematics bringing the story to life on
page 82 chapter 3 establishing the
locations this is where we are on page
84. here they go into the room for
requirement traversing the highlands so
assuming this is the area just outside
of Hogwarts extracurricular activities
on page 186 here then we move to chapter
four the beasts of Hogwarts Legacy on
page 190 214 animating the beasts
chapter 5 golden paths and dark
Mysteries page 218 there and then a
really interesting one playing your way
Page 226 again kind of playing up that
idea of choice and you being the witch
or wizard you want to be casting a spell
on page 228 and then on page 250
continue play
so I mean is this going to be obviously
we'll already have the game in our hands
at this point and of course we know
there's going to be something for you to
explore and do after the fact but it
looks like these Pages here could be a
preview of whatever that may be and then
we move to a page all about the
bathrooms that's right the bathrooms of
Hogwarts like I say you've got the
mermaid right here of course from the
prefix bathroom and then a shot here
inside the prefix bathroom which we have
actually already seen in one of the
trailers by the way then this right here
of course long time fans of the series
Are Gonna Know moaning Myrtle's bathroom
however it wasn't moaning mortal's
bathroom just yet which is what the
description talks about here it mentions
the name Matt's in here so of course
that's most likely Boston Matson on the
Avalanche team and she says bathrooms
are a rather newfangled concept for our
era explains Madison they're exciting
new technology so this is something
students are likely to write home about
to make their parents or great aunts and
uncles jealous of the upgrade great
pride is taken in some of hogwarts's new
plumbing and the bathrooms tend to be
some of the newest nicest looking areas
in the school what would one day be
moaning Myrtle's bathroom and its boys
room counterpart is probably the newest
lavatory in the school so newest
lavatory in the school of course you
guys already know you're already
thinking what I'm thinking right moaning
Merle's bathroom we all know the
significance of that room and that it
does in fact lead to the Chamber of
Secrets of course Slytherin would have
had to have built that when they first
built Hogwarts when they first set that
up Slytherin built that chamber there so
it's interesting that Madsen says this
is one of the newest bathrooms so was
there something else there before that I
mean the pipes and the plumbing I don't
know how all of that would work given
how far back in the past obviously
there's a lot of magic involved as well
of course with an ancient place like
Hogwarts and I'm not going to predict
that we're going to be able to go to the
Chamber of Secrets I know that's been a
popular question among fans will we be
able to go in there I don't think so
however I think there has to be an
Easter egg in here right there has to be
something in here hinting at the
possibility of the Chamber of Secrets
and you just know I mean people are
gonna try you see the way people play
Elder ring and Dark Souls they're gonna
be trying to get get into these areas
but the crazy thing with Harry Potter is
because we already know so much about
the world we know where some of these
entrances are and should be so
everybody's going to be messing around
here in this bad they're trying
everything they can to see if they
cannot get into the Chamber of Secrets
somehow who knows maybe we can and then
unfortunately these images aren't
incredibly high resolution but I'm going
to zoom in a bit here and make this a
little bit more readable for you so it's
just going through as they label each of
these images here so you have the
mermaid over here by Vanessa Palmer
opposite bottom you have the prefect
bathroom which is an in-game render by
the environment team then just here on
the right bathroom doorknob and
Ravenclaw toilet by I think it's b-o-s-i
maybe b-o-s hard to read that one and
then in the bottom Moaning Myrtle
bathroom an in-game render Again by the
environment team and then what I think
will most likely be everyone's favorite
shot from this you have this wonderful
scene of honeydukes and just looking at
all the little candies all the little
details in here the sign saying take
candy here I cannot wait to just get in
and walk around this shop and then even
more details here at the bottom about
some specific candies which chocolate
frogs you guys don't even want to get me
started on the whole lore behind this
and will they or won't they have the
actual wizard cards in them so far we've
seen no evidence that they will I've
talked about it in other videos but
there's this whole thing where in the
Fantastic Beasts movies there was this
one frame of the daily profit where they
talked about the changing of the wizard
card packaging or I guess this should
actually say the chocolate frog
packaging I always say wizard car
packaging and so there's some definite
lore questions there maybe they'll have
the wizard cards maybe they won't but it
certainly does seem like chocolate frogs
are in the game now over here on the
left we have this little description
honeyduk Sweet Shop is a major meeting
place in the town overrun with fizzing
wisbees and chocolate frogs it's run by
Patrick Redding and his daughter Olivia
so there we go getting the names of two
more characters that we're going to be
meeting up with in Hogwarts Legacy then
you have the chocolate frogs here and
then I think this is fizzing wisbees
right here yeah you can see it right
there and then Queen B on the front
there and then over here on the right so
we got top spread honeydukes early
concept by West Studio so that's the one
that we saw just at the top there then
the honeydukes sign design which we just
saw over here on the left chocolate frog
we saw those as well and then right here
we have the fizzing wisbees candy
pumpkin fizz drink they're calling it so
I guess it wasn't actually called
pumpkin juice just yet and then the
strudel pastry right here of course we
also have the absolutely gorgeous cover
art for the game but that's not it all
of these comments and quotes actually
contain several interesting facts let's
jump back in there and read through some
of those as well starting with this line
right here there's such cleverness in
the names of the small towns and their
residents their merchandise and
backstories which Super exciting right I
mean we've wondered how deep are these
towns going to be I mean these people
that we meet are they going to have
stories are they going to have little
routines this is certainly a good sign
how could these not be included she says
learning all about the professors of the
time which we've gotten a little bit of
that with those Professor cards we've
seen so far they're relationships and
their personalities is so important to
your time at Hogwarts same with your
fellow students and the beasts you
encounter so I mean that's like a
preview of the whole book right there
they're telling us we're going to get
character profiles character overviews
your fellow students same professors but
also the Beast as well which we also saw
that reflected in the table of contents
of course now this paragraph here I
found particularly interesting because I
wonder if this means that things
actually change so they're going to look
incorrect in the art book I'll read it
and let me see what you guys think I
liked hanging out with the students and
most of the professors interesting most
but not all the professors there I might
add and encountering new magic the most
challenging was when those characters
were revised or those environments
appeared or disappeared but change is
inevitable whether it was the game
itself or writing about the game and so
we just kept to our mission of making
sure the book was the best it could be
and then maybe the most exciting part of
all especially if you guys are a fan of
this and if you've been looking forward
to this game for a while it says here
while the author is understandably
hesitant to reveal any never before seen
tidbits Hogwarts Legacy reveals about
the Wizarding World she does promise
that the new characters and environments
encountered in Hogwarts Legacy fit
perfectly into the history we know and
the future we know o will be that guys I
mean that tells me there must be
something big there must be something
big in Hogwarts Legacy that happens that
we as fans of the world already know and
we'll be able to see the connection and
point to it and be like yes this is the
beginning of that this is how that
started I mean who knows maybe it's even
something involving the choices that our
character makes which if we have choices
then how would they actually incorporate
that and make it work in the lore I have
no idea but I can't wait to find out and
then finally last line of this paragraph
here one of the most important aspects
of any time spent in The Wizarding World
Is Discovery music to my ears right I
mean just that's what we want to do guys
we want to get lost in this world
and Anyone who reads this book is going
to discover how the game was well
thought out yes please man I am
obviously so excited for the game but
then hearing this about the art book as
well I mean 45 that's that's pretty
steep for an art book you know but
hearing this and the fact that it's 252
Pages it seems like there's going to be
so much packed into this I can't wait to
check it out and if you didn't already
know this 252 page art book from inside
editions is available for pre-order
Amazon is currently listing February
14th and I actually just recently got an
email from Amazon saying that my release
date had been updated and it looks like
after shipping and everything I'm
probably not going to be getting it
until February 16th it does retail for
45 here in the US I'll throw an
affiliate Link in the description below
so if you'd like to use that and help
out the channel a bit we'd appreciate it
guys if you're new here make sure you
hit that subscribe but before you go I
have another awesome video that I'm
going to put here on the right side of
your screen as always thank you all so
much for watching I'll talk to you again
soon